the actions of campus police at the
University of Utah are under scrutiny
today after the shooting death of a
student-athlete
police say the 21 year old Lauren
McCluskey was gunned down Monday night
by her former boyfriend 37 year old
Melvin Rowland who later killed himself
her mother says that Rowland lied about
many things his age his criminal past
and that Lauren had told police he was
harassing her Carter Evans is at the
campus in Salt Lake City with more on
this terrible story
Carter good morning to you good morning
now police say McCluskey was shot by 37
year old Melvin Rowland and her body was
found in a car here on campus now
Rowland is a parolee a registered sex
offender and he had a family
but McCluskey apparently didn't know
that when she recently dated him
students at the University of Utah
remembering Laura McCluskey is a woman
who excelled both in academics and in
track and field a really hard worker
really dedicated athlete her teammates
loved her I know that they're absolutely
heartbroken
according to police McCluskey was gunned
down by Melvin Roland a former boyfriend
in a statement Lauren's mother Jill
McCluskey said she was on the phone with
her daughter as she walked on campus
Monday night suddenly I heard her yell
no no no and that was the last I heard
from her her mother says Lauryn
previously dated her killer for about
one month ending the relationship in
early October after learning he lied to
her about his name his age and his
criminal history a convicted sex
offender Rowland had spent nearly a
decade behind bars
former prosecutor Paul Amon helped put
in there at the time that we arrested me
was 22 years old he was a young man but
he had absolutely zero ability to
control his impulses at the time that we
picked him up on September 17th of 2003
he was attempting to have sex with a 13
year old child Roland told authorities
he was a reformed family man at his last
parole hearing in January but underlying
is I was just ashamed of coming back and
and let my family down being a father
and husband after their breakup earlier
this month
McCluskey filed a complaint to campus
police saying Rowland was harassing her
detectives opened up an investigation
but reportedly did not notify parole
officials University Police chief Dale
Brophy was asked if law enforcement did
enough to protect her I want the answer
to that question as well the detective
had been in contact with Miss McCluskey
and they were working to build a case
dad who first met McCluskey as a
freshman is struggling to make sense of
the tragedy she did the right thing she
tried to get help she you know did the
things that you're supposed to do and
something awful still happens now Roland
fled after McCluskey was shot he was
later found dead of a self-inflicted
gunshot wound now he had violated his
parole and was sent back to prison twice
in this case beyond him somehow he still
slipped through the cracks all right
thank you so much Carter